oh that marvel magic
wasn't nearly as consistent when they
weren't producing their own movies
so i've been thinking about doing this
one for a while
and that is ranking the marvel movies
that weren't produced by marvel well
most of them
i'm actually not going to be including
in this
uh the x-men movies or the spider-man
movies
because both of those have enough of
them that they deserve their own list
i've actually already done an x-men
ranking list and i should do
i should get around to a spider-man one
of these days but
this is for all of the marvel movies
aside from spider-man and x-men that
marvel themselves did not produce so
this stuff kicked off in the 80s and
continued on through into the 2000s
and this is going to be stuff like blade
or howard the duck
or daredevil elektra etc etc etc we'll
get
to uh the actual meat potatoes on this
now there are a few things i did not
include i made a point of not including
a direct to video or made for tv
for the most part i made two exceptions
and i'll bring them up when i get there
but i'm also not including anything
based off an
imprint that marvel owns but it's not
marvel itself so
no kick-ass no kingsmen no men in black
because those are from
impact and malibu imprints respectively
which marvel does
own but that's a stretch to call those
marvel based movies
okay that's enough preamble let's get
into this i have 18
of these to get through let's start at
the bottom
number 18 captain america
from 1990. this is the first of the two
exceptions that i mentioned this is the
one that actually did get
theatrically released in at least some
territories
in europe in america it went straight to
video
and uh rightfully so this thing
look let's be honest there's gonna be a
lot of bad on this list there's gonna be
more bad than there is good
but this one commits the ultimate sin
it's
boring the action scenes are not well
constructed or shot they clearly didn't
have a proper
uh stunt team or someone who knew how to
shoot action scenes really at all
the plot just meanders all over the
place captain america
battles the red skull loses early on and
then spends the rest of the movie
slowly getting to the point where he
will battle the red skull again and what
happens in between is a whole lot of
nothing there's also the weird thing
that they made the red skull
an italian fascist rather than a german
nazi as he normally is i'm fairly
certain that happened because they shot
in
italy like that doesn't really hurt it
but there's also there's a there's a
handful of bizarre decisions like
we have a full red skull makeup in the
opening
but then when we see him after that he's
like had i don't know if it's plastic
surgery it's not a mask i don't think it
never gets pulled off and he looks more
like
jigsaw from punisher and i don't know
why
but again it's just boring it's bland
and nobody gives a really good
performance even people who are decent
actors
so yeah very forgettable
number 17 the punisher
from 1989 starring dolph lundgren
this was kind of weird uh experience
watching this because when i started it
the way it opened i actually found
myself going you know what
this isn't that bad little 80s cheesy
little
later parts of the death wish series
kind of vibe to it but like this
isn't horrible and then dolph lundgren
started speaking
here's the thing i actually think dolph
lundgren has become a better actor as
time has gone on but in the 80s
he was a physical presence he could give
good just vibe he he
just standing there drew your attention
but
the man couldn't read a line worth a
darn
and you know when it opened and we just
saw him going about his thing i'm like
yeah maybe then he started talking he's
like oh never mind and then
uh unfortunately ultimately much like
captain america it is
boring and that's that's the ultimate
sin there's some
weird odd bits of comedy with some of
the uh
italian mob guys who all talk like this
you know
i'm like oh geez so just generic
dull moving on number 16
ghost rider spirit of vengeance this
would be the second ghost rider film
starring nicholas cage i had a lot of
hopes for this
it's got an interesting cast i mean nick
cage's well he's always interesting at
the very least
has idris elba in it had the guys who
directed crank which is a movie i really
liked but the thing that i've learned
having looked at
most of the movies they've made since
then including crank two and this
um they uh that they really should have
just stopped
crank was the perfect excuse to do what
they do this
high frenetic never letting up pace but
honestly
that wears you out when you start a
movie at 11
and you just keep it there it's the same
as starting and keeping it as one it
never modulates it never varies and it
just becomes monotonous
no matter how intense or hard-hitting it
is if it's
you're just hitting the same note at the
same level of intensity the whole way
through
who cares and that's ultimately it just
grinds you down
it's when high octane insane
camera work action becomes boring simply
because it never lets up that's
i guess kind of an accomplishment and
that's what happened here
number 15. phant 4 stick
or fantastic four this was the one that
josh trank directed
kind of it got taken away from him and
redone
and uh it's a mess like i
i have no doubt that tranq's cut was
probably more coherent
and uh better film but
even the parts of this that are good
aren't that
good so i can't imagine it would have
been that much better
but what we ended up with is this very
bizarre film that
wavers back and forth on tone a few
times has a lot of
very unengaged performances and it
basically has
a first yo your standard 3x structure of
a film
this thing basically has a first act
that
lasts for an hour and 15 minutes no
second act and then a 15 minute long
third act
it's bizarre this thing
not in a way that's particularly
interesting but definitely in a
oh you could tell this thing was
frankenstein together out of pieces of a
film that nobody wanted to
finish way number 14
howard the duck the very first marvel
movie
ever made for theaters how's that for a
distinction a lot of people probably
thought this was going to be
lower on the list especially if they
watched me live stream my reaction to
that because it kind of broke
my brain a little bit but that in a way
kind of speaks to its merit
it's bad do not get me wrong but it's
bad
in really bizarre ways it's the kind of
bad where you're like
i haven't seen a movie fail in the ways
this has failed before
it's bad in a really unique fashion and
that honestly has some entertainment
value i would have happily put it higher
except it's almost two hours long
even if you're fun bad which this
arguably
is that's too long if this was an hour
and a half honestly
i would have put it several thoughts
higher than this as it stands i'm like
i watched it once it's kind of
an amazing oddity but it's too dang long
to suffer through again
number 13 fantastic for rise of the
silver surfer
i'm actually kind of bitter about this
film for a very personal reason because
it's not
really any worse than the
earlier fantastic form not or one i
talked about earlier the one that
preceded it
um but i still rank this one lower
because
okay here's the thing i'll get to that
other fantastic four movie in a little
bit
but that one had some things that worked
for me and i was prepared to make
allowances because
in a lot of ways it felt like the proper
template for how to do
these movies wasn't fully solidified
some things were clearly still getting
worked out
and i was prepared to make allowances
i'm like okay just learn from your
mistakes
but then they came and made the second
movie and like it's all the same
mistakes
you did the exact same things you didn't
even try to improve you just went
ah same thing as last time they'll eat
it up again
no when you when you give me
a poorly cooked meal out of a dish that
sounded good on the menu you know what
maybe i'll give you a pass one time
saying well i'm sure they won't cook it
like that again
and then they serve you the same thing
again you don't go back to that
restaurant
food analogies that's what this has
driven me to moving on
number 12 ghost rider
two things that make this worth watching
one is nicolas cage because
the man clearly wants to be here and you
can tell
and he's great and then henry fonda
that's kind of it though and a bit like
howard the duck this
could have ranked higher if it wasn't so
dang long it's another one damn near two
hours
should have been 90 minutes a hundred
max this thing is too long and bloated
and even though cage kind of keeps the
thing moving forward well enough to get
through to the end it's just like
once you get there like okay
number 11 one that most people probably
put significantly lower than i'm about
to
uh elektra again it's not good we're not
even close to getting the ones that i
would even
argue are even kind of good but
i don't know i felt like the movie knew
what it was it was
cheesy vaguely uh martial arts kung fu
movie
influence kind of thing i enjoyed it
like not in a way that i would ever
recommend it but i remember
by the time it was done going all right
i don't want my money back that's that's
the level we've reached with these
movies
moving on number ten
the other exception that i made to my
rules and this one just
because i wanted to include it i can't
even justify why this is on here
fantastic four the one directed by roger
corman
the one that never got released and that
was
buried now depending on who you ask this
thing was never intended to be released
at all it was simply
made to cash in on the license and then
more or less blackmailed the uh the
studios that wanted to make the movie
into
buying out the rights and ensuring that
it never got
distributed and damaged the brand roger
corman always insisted that he was
legitimately planning to release this
movie
either way you know what there's a low
budget fun to it and unlike
say the 90 the 1990s captain america
this it does have that energy and that
scrappiness that can make low budget
films kind of fun even though they're
not
very good the captain america didn't
have that this
does and the effects are cheesy and
lame but there's just an energy to it
and like
the doctor doom and it yeah i wish i
could remember
his slime but he has this one part where
he's like he says something to the
effect of
and you will never stop me
he just wiggles his fingers i don't know
why
but i love that it's still not good
though
number nine blade trinity
this one uh down this low partly for
crapping over what had previously been a
really dang solid series but you know
wesley snipes was kind of checked out he
doesn't completely phone it in he does
well enough i think it probably helps
that he had the sunglasses on so
if he had been checked out it would have
shown in his eyes but you see his eyes
so rarely
yeah okay but you know they bring in
other characters to pull the weight
because he doesn't seem to want to be
there that much you've got
ryan reynolds doing kind of a proto
deadpool with his take on hannibal king
and it works well enough it just isn't
at the level of the previous two movies
and then the villain sinks it
like i like dominic purcell like i love
him
in legends of tomorrow he's amazing
might be he's probably my favorite
character on there but here as dracula
it just it does not work the presence
that he brings to this
is so wrong for this character it's a
it's an awful miscast and it kind of
sinks
the whatever hope the film might have
had so we've hit the halfway mark here
and we've been talking about a lot of
bad movies and
it's not always easy to power through
these things you know can help
this video sponsor because we're
sponsored today by zest
t available as canned sparkling tea bag
teas loose teas and even cbd
products it has more caffeine than a cup
of coffee
and can help power you through even the
dullest or most painful films
we've all got our tricks on how to get
through this and if you go to zesty and
you use
the coupon code nathaniel you can
actually get free shipping on your first
order so
check them out and power through your
own
ill-advised marathon of badness
number eight fantastic four
the actual one that got a proper
theatrical release and was a finished
film like i said i'm not sure i can make
an argument that is actually that much
better than fantastic four rise of the
silver surfer but i'm just
spiteful at that one here's the main
thing that this one had
this thing honestly captured the
family dynamic of the characters really
well
arguably each characters in a vacuum
wasn't spot on sue's a little
okay although then again sue storm is a
difficult character to update especially
depending on what era you're looking at
her from
same with reed uh to be honest and they
were the the two kind of weekends but
their ability to bounce off each other
and
more importantly ben grimm and johnny
who were both fantastic and were
perfectly cast they buoy a lot with
their presence in general but the
dynamic of those four
that has the family dynamic that
i love you but you drive me crazy
feeling that
the fantastic four should have and i was
so happy that they captured that that
it's always kind of bolstered it a bit
in my mind
and as far as this dr doom goes he's
actually not a bad villain
he's not dr doom like at all
they get him so nothing ever gets him
right
but uh he's a perfectly serviceable
villain as long as you don't think
about the character that he's supposed
to be
number seven hulk angley's
hulk a lot of things wrong with this
film but you know what it is
it's interesting it's an interesting
take on the hulk this whole
element of the sins of the father of
going for something almost operatic in
the way that it's dealing with the
conflicts between the characters and the
ways that they
affect each other it doesn't work
and like a lot of people knock the
editing the sort of
trying to imitate panels almost from a
comic book
i actually think it's a really neat idea
i'm i'm not
sure it works i mean so many people
dislike that i think it's pretty clear
that it didn't work but
i thought that was a really neat idea
and there's a lot of things about this
and i'm just like
that's a neat idea that's an interesting
idea then
you know at the same time you have on
the far side of that eric banner who is
not a bad actor but is not able to
convey
really much of anything in this
and then you have things like the hulk
dogs and the ending that makes
no friggin sense and is almost
completely in the dark so you can't tell
what's going on
at all yeah there's some
there's some things that are worth sort
of pondering in this one but
then no number six
daredevil we've reached the ones that i
would actually
comfortably say are good movies
and i should qualify that i'm talking
about the theatrical cuts in all of
these that's most relevant here because
this has a director's cut
that lots of people say is better i
don't think it is i think he just bloats
the run time with
a lot of stuff that honestly was better
left on the cutting room floor i like
the flow and the tightness of the
theatrical cup better
sue me regardless ben affleck does a
really solid job as matt murdock
colin farrell is bullseye not comic book
acura at all but you know what
fun and then
the late great michael clark duncan as
kingpin
he's so good he is awesome as kingpin
it's a really terrific slightly out of
the box
pick he's great his presence is awesome
you could tell he really wanted to play
this part he lobbied for this
and you can feel the joy that he has in
getting to play this character
jennifer garner does solid work as
elektra the editing in the fight scenes
is not good it's cut heavy and it
doesn't follow
decent geography at all and also
ultimately it's biggest thing as it
tries to do too much because it tries to
establish daredevil bring an electra do
her entire story arc including her
dying deal with bullseye and deal with
the kingpin all in one film
it's too much i think it does most of
that stuff competently but in a way that
none of it
gets the space to breathe that it needs
and yes
even in the director's cup with the
added time it's still too much for one
movie and i still prefer the tighter
version
number five the punisher
starring thomas jane now this one
i i want to be really clear i've always
liked this movie
even before thomas james was in the
dirty laundry short
which is a much more accurate to the
comics uh take on the punisher and a lot
of people actually
kind of felt he redeemed his take on it
there
here's the thing about this movie i've
always liked it as a film
in and of itself as a pretty dang solid
revenge movie
is it a good punisher movie not
especially
it's been pointed by more hardcore fans
of punisher
that you know doing things like pulling
out a fake
um fire hydrant to get somebody a ticket
like that's not the punisher what is
this
and i agree but i still think it's a
solid revenge movie as long as you were
not
expecting an absolute comic accurate
frank castle just mowing his way through
everybody
he did he does still take people down
though and i think thomas jane
gives a good performance i think john
travolta gives a good performance that's
actually quite a nuanced one from him in
this
i think everybody's on their game and it
pulled enough
recognizable elements from the
punisher you know some specific things
and some broad things that
i still like it i do get why punisher
fans
specifically don't like it though
because it feels like a
softer version of the punisher and
that's fair
that's legit i still think it's a really
solid revenge movie though
and i like a good revenge movie so there
you go
number four blade
you know people give a lot of credit to
the first
x-men movie for sort of kicking down
the door and helping to eradicate the
stigma
of comic book movies after batman and
robin or they'll also give credit to sam
raimi spider-man
for you know upping the theatricality of
it
people don't give blade it's due
because first off this thing predates
the matrix by
two years and look at it
look at the style of it look at the feel
of it the thing was
it was groundbreaking for what was gonna
become
very standard for the action genre
wesley snipes is
terrific in the part the music is fun
the action is cool
the whole thing just has a great fun
vibe to it and oh steven dorf
again not comic book accurate as deacon
frost but
man is he fun i enjoy the heck out of
this movie
the tail end and the at the climax the
final confrontation
feels a bit undercooked which they
completely redid the climax and what
they
decided to do was better than what they
were originally planning to do but it's
still
underwhelmed slightly that's about the
only real knock i have on this thing
if you're into late 90s action slightly
cheese excessive gore
yeah i dig it number three
punisher war zone now here's the thing
about this one with the thomas jane
punisher i mentioned how i understood
why
punisher fans fans of him in the comics
didn't really like it this one punisher
warzone
i understand why critics didn't like it
and i definitely understand why it
flopped with the mainstream
but i will never understand why comic
book fans craft on this thing
this is an amazing representation of the
punisher
because it captures the main thing
that basically every other adaptation
i've seen of the punisher including the
netflix version
completely misses the punisher
is darkly hilarious
the punisher at his best is not just
some grim and
gritty guy blowing everybody away the
comic at its best
has a sense of humor and not in a cracky
one-liners way but in
uh well in the way this movie does
like the fact that the best way to
exemplify this i think is
the punisher has
this guy from the mob in a room and
there's an fbi guy with him played by
colin salmon who's very good
um and the fbi guy's calling it in
and the punisher
damn it frank like he dropped the
casserole
and jigsaw first of all looks
looking fantastic gives this huge
overblown patriotic speech
to get all these gangs on his side to
try and take on the punisher
it's ridiculous it's perfect
it's wonderful and ray stevenson
oh god he's so awesome in this part
it takes a very special kind of actor to
be able to deliver a line like
sometimes i wish i could get my hands on
god
and make you enjoy it and not roll your
eyes
this thing is dark comedy
gold and i love it
number two blade
ii guillermo del toro coming in to take
what was already cool about blade
just make it a little bit cooler by
going with a
slightly different look this sort of
diseased
strain of vampires his whole aesthetic
with
elements of body horror this gothic
storytelling
it's a perfect addition and despite it
being a pretty hard swerve from the more
clean and cut and dry approach that
stephen norrington had in the first film
it still feels organic from it
wesley snipes on point terrific the
entire way through the whole
thing is just dripping with atmosphere
and mood and i genuinely like the
reapers they're kind of unsettling which
they should the standard vampires
they're hard to make unsettling
and the cast otherwise is great
danny john jules is terrific ron
perlman's in this
uh norman reedus ah is a fun movie
and as is kind of unique to del toro fun
in that
slightly dirty slimy way
yeah it's good time
and number one this might feel like a
cheap because
while not mcu it is still produced by
disney but it's not continuity so i'm
counting it
big hero 6.
yeah this thing is not
comic book accurate not even a little
bit but it's a really good time
it has possibly my favorite depiction of
a robot in
all of film certainly possibly all of
fiction
because the film never forgets that he
processes like a machine
he doesn't become more human he doesn't
have a human soul
baymax is just a really well programmed
piece of equipment
but he's still wonderful and lovable and
all of the characters bounce off each
other in really great ways
the villain while the twist that they
play with it doesn't
doesn't fully work but the villain is
threatening which is what he ultimately
needs to be
this movie if i watch it on the right
day you can make me cry
sometimes i really think it's fantastic
i think it's an underrated movie i think
it's a shame we never got a proper
sequel i know it had a tv show that's
not the same thing
and if i'm going to be completely honest
i'm slightly biased because it was the
first movie
i ever took my daughter to
and to see in the theater
is that an objective reason to put it at
top no but it's my reason and it's my
list and i think it's a great movie
big hero 6 at number one on a pile of
largely not very good movies how would
you rank these how many of these have
you seen
i had to cram together that 1989
punisher
howard the duck and the 1990 captain
america in fairly short order to be able
to do this because
oh boy i hadn't seen in those and
but what do you think about it whatever
your thoughts are drop something down
the comments
let's talk about it in addition to the
sponsorship from zesty
link below use the coupon code i also
have a patreon yes
i can show for myself as well as other
companies
so check that out if you wish to support
what i do
keep the lights on and this whole thing
going but it also helps me out if you do
the usual like share subscribe
all that stuff you know what it is but
um you also don't have to
end of the day you're the council i'm
just running the meetings
and until next time this council is
[Music]
adjourned
[Music]
[Music]
wow
now
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign